could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
kobe bryant was not interested in
winning championships
he was obsessed he was the trainer for
dwyane wade kobe bryant michael jordan
the book is relentless tim rover what is
your dark side after every semester of
anatomy class you have dead bodies my
dad's job was to dispose of those bodies
you have to cut off their legs you have
to cut off their head i saw him do that
when i was four years old
it doesn't get any darker than that
if i spoke to some of your clients and i
asked them what was tim good at for you
what would they say to me elevating them
to another level very few people
understand what winning does to an
individual's mental health
winning doesn't make you heartless but
it teaches you to use your heart less
every decision i've made i knew what the
cost was going to be if you think the
price of winning is too high wait till
you get the bill from regret
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo usa edition i hope
nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
tim
i read in your book winning the
unforgiving race to greatness
chapter 12.
and i don't usually start with people's
books i wanna i wanna you usually start
somewhere else but
in chapter 12 you talk about this this
concept of the dark side and the darkest
side right there huh yeah yeah and the
reason i want to go right there is
because i actually think it's the start
for many people it's the start
so tell me about your
dark side and where
and what it came from
this is a very unique story so
my father both my parents are indian
descent
so they came over to
the states when i was four my mother
came over first
she was a nurse practitioner
and my dad was a professor in india so
when he came over
from india to the uk he was still a
professor over there when he came from
uk to the united states
they said that his education would not
transfer
that he could not he wasn't qualified
enough to teach
at the
university level
in the states
so my dad said okay well what job do you
have available
so they had a job back then it was
called a degreaser
a degreaser
is an individual doesn't this job does
not exist anymore
after every
quarter or every semester of anatomy
class
you have cadavers cadavers cadavers dead
bodies
my dad's job was to dispose
of those bodies
now this is a man that was called a
doctor
back in the old country
now when you dispose of these cadavers
it's not a garbage truck that comes and
picks them up
you have to dismantle them
you have to cut off their legs
you have to cut off their arms
you have to cut off their head
and you throw them in a furnace
i saw
him do that when i was four years old
my parents couldn't afford babysitters
my mom worked at night
my dad worked during the day so when you
were off from school
guess what
you can't disturb mom because she's
worked 16 hours at night you go to work
with your dad
my dad said
he goes son
never let your pride get in the way
of doing what's necessary and providing
for the people you love
it doesn't get any darker than that
you still feel it today
very
i wouldn't be here if it wasn't for him
and the things that he did
both of them
never complained
went to work every single day
as you were telling me that story what
was the emotion
you know what people talk about
sacrifice
that others did for them very few get to
actually witness it and remember
there's certain memories that people
have
when you go way back in age and they
can't even remember i have vivid
memories
of those things
and how not only did they mold him how
they molded my brother
the effects it had on both of us
positive and negative
and i understand
how to use
that darkness
in the most
positive way just like my dad did
because to him
that darkness
was a new beginning
he didn't look at it as
an individual who like i'm so
accomplished back over here
he was just grateful and thankful to be
in the united states and have a new
opportunity and a new beginning
for his family
and i always say this and this is why
when we talk about
the dark and the darkness and the dark
side and all that other stuff
people forget this
i always say this
when does a new day
start
it starts at midnight
is it dark outside at midnight
yes
so if a new day and a new beginning
starts in the dark every day
that's when your new beginnings start
but so many people are afraid
to go to that place
and i tell them
you have to visit that place because if
that place comes visits you it will
never leave if you go visit
the
darkness that you've been running from
you'll have the opportunity to leave a
better person
you'll have a better understanding of
yourself you have better understanding
of your purpose
but if you don't take that trip
and the darkness comes visits you it's a
guest that will never leave
that dark side you referenced it did
good and bad things for you
negatives and positives what are the
negatives
it hardened me
it it it really it hardened me it
hardened me to the point where
i had a hard time communicating with
other individuals and a hard time
understanding
things that were so easy for me to deal
with
the hardships
the trials and tribulations
and i would see other people
complain about things and i'm like what
are you complaining about i don't i was
just like i couldn't relate to it
i just i just couldn't relate to it i
didn't have much compassion for that for
those in for those individuals
and you talk in the book that
often
you're visited at night by
a presence
in the early hours of the morning
every night there's an individual
that comes visit you
you know everybody has
everybody has these grand grandioso
dreams and these day dreams about
success and money and fame and power
and i always say
winning never visits you in your
daydreams it sees you in your nightmares
the things that you come visit you in
your nightmares those things are real
those are the things that you have to
deal with those are the monsters
underneath the bed those are the
skeletons in the closet
those are the things that you've put
away and some of the stuff that you've
put away and you don't want to deal with
is some of the best part of you
how many times have you heard this
people always say
you know always show up
positive
you know always bring your positivity
well
that means you only bring half of you
that means you're not accepting the
other half
you got to bring the light you got to
bring the dark
you got to bring the good
you got to bring the bad
you have to have conversations
with those skeletons in your closets
they know you better than you know
yourself
in order to stand out
in order to fight
many times you have to become that
monster
but most individuals when they become
that monster they don't know how to
control it
and they let the monster control them
so it's a learning process
and all those years that you run from
that monster underneath your bed you're
actually being taught can you control
that monster or is that monster gonna
control you
and once you recognize that part of that
monster or all that monster is you
that's when you can actually start
fulfilling your dreams and living the
life that you're meant to live
how did that monster manifest itself in
your behavior outside of you said about
you struggle to be compassionate with
other people you struggle to have
empathy for their their struggles
was there other things that you where
that monster would rear its ugly head or
take control of you
you know what when the monster took over
it wasn't for bad things it allowed me
to deal
with
you know how mean kids could be the
different the different bully the
bulliness in school that every kid goes
to whether it's physical or mental you
know the teasing all that other stuff
that monster allowed me to get gave me
that strength to
not to lash out back at those
individuals
and just say hey continue trust yourself
continue on this continue on this path
all right and don't worry about
trying to prove those individuals wrong
you and i will prove ourselves right
when you talk about and this is what i
was trying to gauge when i was listening
to your audiobook you talk about these
at 2am realizing you're not alone and i
wasn't sure if you were being literal
or figurative you were i wasn't sure if
you literally felt the presence of
spirits or someone else in your room or
you meant or it was a figurative way to
talk about the thoughts that were in
your mind it's both
it's both
when you get out of bed or you want to
get out of bed
there's all these individuals that are
lined up
next to that bed
there's fear
there's doubt
there's compassion there's hatred
there's excellence
there's sorrowness
there's excuses
and they all have their hands out
literally literally
and then you get to choose
every single day
who gets a vote
it's your decision
it's your decision
and most times
many individuals
make their decisions
with their
feelings and when you have to make those
decisions with your mind
every single morning
if you can't get out of your beds
and you choose not to win
you listen to your feelings
if you chose to get out of bed
and you said there's a win for me
that's your mind
and each one of those individuals you
decide who gets a vote and some days not
all the popular
things are going to get a vote success
may not get a vote winning may not get a
vote
but
you've made that decision that now
this thing
gets a vote
i must be ready to deal with it
every single day
there's something
different
there also has to be something different
about yourself
and i said this in winning
different
scares
people
when you're different it scares people
when the world is different it scares
people everything different
scares people
but
it attracts
the right
emotions it attracts the right feelings
it attracts right thoughts and it
attracts the right
people because the people that are
willing
to not judge you and understand and know
that these things are real
they are real
they will tell you
i understand with both books that i've
written people were like i thought i was
the only one
because this is not
it's not accepted to talk about these
things
because people put you in this land of
you're crazy
and anytime anybody's told me i'm crazy
i've always thanked them for that
because it gave me the ability to see
and do things
that other people can't do and
acknowledge things that other people
won't acknowledge
it seems to be a bit of a paradox that
sometimes our dark side whatever that
might be it could be being bullied in
school and the consequences that had or
you know as you say in the book as well
being overweight and being bullied for
that or some trauma or whatever you've
had in your life it seems to be a
paradox that our dark side can both be
the driving force of our life and also
the cause of so much pain
so it can be the thing to put us in pain
and then also the thing that drives us
out of pain
if that makes sense it makes 100 well
you know you look at it
it's
for
a lot of individual
you know
the physical pain that they put
themselves through is actually their
pleasure you know my athletes when they
the at the highest level of their
training
it is the most uncomfortable state they
put themselves through every single
day
and people are just like i'm just not
gonna i'm not gonna do that they see
people that run the ultra marathons it's
people that take these these ice baths
it's you know it's it's all it's all out
there
now that doesn't mean if you do those
things you're gonna you're gonna excel
in other aspects of your life
but it does
raise your level of understanding
that
nothing great
is going to come
without you having
to deal with what i call adversity and
pain tolerance
you must be able to deal with that and
the more
understanding you have of what's causing
you the pain and how you've dealt with
it
is going to determine how successful
you will be in whatever you choose
in life you know you have individuals
who will become from
a broken family
and you could have two children that
come from the broken family
and
one individual
will
will not live up to their potential
and they'll say
it's because
i came from a broken family
and then you have the other individuals
same environment same household same
everything
would do
great things
not only for themselves for humanity for
this world and what's their answer
because i came from a broken family
they both understood how to use the pain
one used it to excel
the other used it to deny
having done this podcast for the amount
of amount of time that i've done it
what you've articulated there about that
broken home scenario
um is the thing i've always played
around with which is
a trauma causes an adverse response
typically
greatness or despair yes and it's and
i've always tried to figure out what a
trauma is going to do but it's been
impossible to for me but in your case it
led you to be
great
in what you do and what you achieved in
your life and the people you worked with
so tell me about how you went from that
traumatic early
upbringing that created that dark side
in you
to
being a sports enhancement specialist
that's how you that's how you prefer
yes that was my official title when i
was
when my main
job was
to train profession to train
professional athletes so i didn't want i
never wanted to consider myself and
label myself as a trainer because i did
i did more i did more than that so i
actually came up with that that title
myself
so i played college basketball myself i
had these dreams of playing professional
basketball
wasn't wasn't good enough okay but i was
like
what can i do
to make sure this doesn't happen to
other individuals
and i was like you know what
i started to study the body really
really
closely
which goes all the way back to
when i was four years old
so not only did i have to study the body
from an external standpoint i had to
learn it from an
internal internal standpoint
going through the different injuries
that i suffered through
my years of working out training
playing allowed me to understand what an
individual goes to not only from a
physical standpoint i understood what
was going on
in their head if they hurt their ankle
hip
back
all that stuff
i knew so not only was i able to train
them from a physical standpoint i was
able to train them from a psychological
standpoint i know what you're going
through i know the barriers
that you have to go that you have to go
through because it's so much easier
to get an individual back
from a physical injury
but it's that mental scar that stays
with them
how what do you have to do to make them
forget about that mental scar
and that's where my that's where my
niche came in like okay i need you to go
out there and play and play at the
highest level and not worry about
what happened
six months ago
nine months ago
six weeks ago
so when it became sports enhancement
the enhancement part the sports was the
physical the enhancement part
was
was the mental
if i spoke to some of your clients that
knew you best
michael jordan
kobe
and all these others and i know you work
now with a lot of ceos a lot of business
leaders etc
and i asked them what is tim good at
what was tim good at for you what would
they say to me
elevating
elevating them to another level
holistically holistically
just being able because when somebody
comes up to me and they said
i want to be
something
and i look at it well somebody's already
done that i need more
you can't come to me and just say i want
to be everyone says i want to be the
world's best tennis player i want to be
the world's best basketball player i
want to be the world's greatest pop pop
podcaster what
that's already been done
there's another level you're not
thinking big enough
my individuals come to me and say listen
i have these dreams i have these
thoughts
and the first thing i tell them
your dreams and thoughts better be so
big that they better scare you
they better scare you
why because you're not thinking big
enough then you don't want it
it has to be something that nobody else
has thought about before or done before
the process it takes to be number one
and stay at number one
you have no you have no idea
you have an idea because you've been
there
everybody wants to sit in your seat
until they have to sit in your seat
very few people understand
what winning and success does to an
individual's mental health
everybody thinks the more you win the
more successful you are
it just makes everything so much easier
and they don't understand the pressures
that these individuals
put on themselves
to continue
to perform at the highest level
to have their businesses win
over and over again
when you reach
a million followers on your social media
it's a
[Music]
different
level
of pressure
than an individual who isn't
winning all the time who hasn't been
successful at the highest level at the
highest level who's not being critiqued
about every decision they make
about what they wear
about what they say
where they go
and that's a whole different level
of
mental health that success brings
that a lot of people just don't
understand
michael
i uh i watched the last dance
documentary
i saw you in there as well
um
really i've got to be honest i
didn't really know much about mj before
that
and it went from me watching that
documentary
getting obsessed with him
to hanging a picture on the wall in my
office back in london
um very soon after a neon sign in my
office in london just of that silhouette
for many many reasons but as i read
through your story and a lot of my
listeners won't know about this so
i feel obliged because i know the
question they'll be asking is how on
earth did you go from
a college graduate that was you know
earning three dollars an hour as a
trainer in a gym
to
becoming
the trainer of
all the sports enhancement specialists
for
michael jordan who many see as one of
the greatest if not the greatest
sporting athletes of all time
what happened in that gap
well
when
i started to go to college i didn't know
what i wanted to do
and
you know again being of
indian descent and having both parents
and in the medical in the medical field
you get to choose
two options
as a career
one being a doctor
and this is back in the 80s
second being a doctor
that's it
and i told my parents i do not want to
go
i don't want to be a doctor they said
well what do you want to do
i said i want to train professional
athletes i knew this very early
i knew this very very very very early
because when i was a freshman in college
there was a
uh a class it was the first time it was
being offered at the school it was
called kinesiology just movement of the
muscles and body
and
basically movement movement of
humans
and i took it kind of picked up a book
and i started i said you know what
this is for me
so when people kept telling me why are
you going to take this class why
everybody said oh you know most people
that take these
courses end up being in the health
industry whether it be studying science
working in administrations in colleges
or being uh health educators and i just
like no there's there's something more
out there for me
there's something there's something more
out there for me
and then when we
we'd have
our basketball practices in college and
so forth and i was like
all we're doing is just we're just
running running we're doing stuff
without a purpose
this this this can't this can't be this
can't be right this can't be right and
we had an individual that would come in
and
work our team out i was just like this
doesn't just
this doesn't feel right
so i really took study to this i really
wanted to understand this
later on i graduated with a master's
degree
parents were like
you know well you got this you can't
stay at home gotta go get a job master's
degree in master's degree in exercise
science
all right
and
i took a job at a local health club
the minimum wage back then was
and 35 cents
i took the job
i took the job
they did not allow i was the most
qualified
individual they had on their training
staff but they still wouldn't allow me
to train because i had to do the
six-month
probation period
so i said okay no problem so what i did
was i worked in the exercise rooms i
basically cleaned the clean the
equipment opened up the gyms did
different different different stuff
different stuff like that and then after
six months passed by they said okay you
have to take this exam
and if you pass the exam we'll allow you
to be a trainer well what
the funny part about is when i looked at
the exam it was the exam i actually
wrote as one of my projects
for school and this and this health club
was using the exam i actually wrote to
certify their trainers [ __ ]
crazy
so i looked at this exam i i gave all
the answers and i gave it to them and
they they scored and they said you got
100 you're able to qualify as a trainer
i said thank you i said where'd you guys
get that from
they said you know oh you know what we
got it from you from a university i said
which university
and they said university of illinois
chicago i said yeah i said you should
really follow up and see
who developed that exam
so they came back later on and said
you wrote this i said yes i'm the one
that wrote this exam i'm the one that
wrote this is that so i became the
trainer over there and in a very short
period of time
i became the highest grossing trainer
they had
in the in there but what was great about
it is
and i talked about this in the book
school taught me
what to think
all the education all the books
everything i knew exactly what to what
to think
but when you start dealing with humans
who are able to communicate and who have
their own thoughts and have their own
beliefs and have their own feelings have
their own emotions have their own ideas
i was like
as a whole part of my education that's
missing here
my schooling taught me what to think
now i need to learn how to think
there's a big difference between the two
and once i started training individuals
understanding
how
different people adapted to the
different ways of communicating
different times of working out different
words different facial expressions
whether
different levels of silence
that's when i really started to manifest
my trade and understand the results
with all the different type of
individuals and these weren't just
athletes he was everybody who wanted to
just get into shape lose weight get
stronger jump higher run a little faster
play better tennis whatever it may be
but i'm sitting here and i'm like i'm
only using
maybe 10 percent of what i've learned in
school there's got to be more
and there was a small article in the
local newspaper that said michael jordan
was tired of taking the physical abuse
from the detroit pistons
and wanted to get stronger
like okay
so i said you know what
now back then remember there's no cell
phones no emails
you just uh
there's no way of direct messaging
social media there's no way of direct
messaging anybody so i said i'm gonna
write
letters there's 15 players on a
basketball team i'm going to write 14
letters the one person i'm not going to
write a letter to is michael jordan
he's the best why would he why would he
work with an individual that's never
worked with a professional athlete so i
wrote 14 letters explaining my
background
what what i do what my training
philosophy is and back then you put a
stamp in it you go to the post office
you put them in the mail
and they get delivered to the player's
training facility and they get thrown in
the locker as fan mail
whether the player decides to open it up
or not that's up to them
well obviously somebody opened up one of
the letters
and michael saw it in some
in somebody else's locker pulled the
letter out
read it and gave it to the team
physician and the athletic trainer
during that time and said hey
find out what this is about
i have to pause you there just to
highlight
the fact that most people would not send
those letters i'm not most
there's nothing about me that qualifies
as most there's nothing that qualifies
me me as me as average because you know
what
what's the worst thing that could have
possibly happened i'd be in the exact
same situation i was in
i wasn't gonna be any worse
if i didn't take that initiative i
didn't take that action
i was in a worse situation
in hindsight yeah
but it's so it's so interesting because
that those moments riddle my story where
i sent um
the first one was just sending emails to
at nine to eighteen years old to say
same people were you invested in my
company at 18 after dropping out of
university and i i talk about this and
this is why i paused you because
it happened when i was 16 happened when
i was 18 happened when i was 24 and
those were pivotal moments in my life
and as you say if i rolled the dice and
got a bad hand i was in the same place
but but it was free to it was like free
to roll in your case it cost you a
couple of stamps to roll
and it baffles my mind that you know the
people the young people that listen to
this podcast that are trapped in the
situation they're in aren't just rolling
the [ __ ] dice every day to see if
they can get a michael jordan
the best of the best
they're always looking for a competitive
edge
they're always looking for that
that
.001 percent thing that can make them
better i had a conversation i and this
individual i never i'd i've never worked
with but he was an event
that i was speaking at also and he spoke
but he spoke before me michael phelps oh
yeah all right for anybody that doesn't
know michael phelps maybe the most
accomplished olympic swimmer of all time
yes
so michaels
said that he trained
every single day he was he was
he was at the pinnacle of his career and
he said it's not like i can go ahead and
i can knock off three seconds
he goes i train every single day
so i can shave
0.001 second
he goes that's my ultimate goal after
three four months of getting ready for
my next race or years whatever it is i
need to be i need to shave
.0001 off my time
and everybody he surrounded himself with
that was their job
marginal gains as we call it that one
percent that 0.1
and i i heard you talk about this with
with kobe in the book and your other
athletes um that that trying to find
that edge and kobe was one of those
people that in the book that you talk
about really trying to find that edge as
well um in his career
i'm really compelled by the concept of
marginal gains because
i feel like it's been my religion for my
life and my team here hearing me talk
about this so much that they're sick of
it which was which is like how do we
make what we're doing here all my
businesses but let's just focus on what
we see here one percent better so
whether it means
putting these little things up to stop
the reflection in there whether it means
you know the effort they went to to put
these things up like that is my religion
and when i when you sat down here i said
this podcast has been going for about a
year and we're number one and that is
purely based on the fact that we believe
the one percent will change our
trajectory in an invisible way in the
moment but in a profound way over time
yes how important are those marginal
gains
to the athletes that you've worked with
and in the work you do with them still
today it's everything
it's everything and it's in the details
you know you just described all these
little things and somebody coming on it
doesn't matter
you know a great example was like you
know what when we handed you the book
you're like this cover is so much better
than the other one
switch it
it's the little attention to the little
things that people
everyone thinks they won't notice you
hear this all the time don't sweat the
small stuff
the one percenters the 0.01 they sweat
every
single
detail
because the one thing they let slips
somebody is going to use that to their
advantage somebody is going to make a
big deal out of it and they're going to
feel like
they left something out you know
everyone says don't worry about the
things that you can't control
well these individuals
they want to control everything they can
control so the uncontrollable becomes
more manageable to them so if they pay
attention to every single detail
obsessively over and over and over again
that when the uncontrollable
happens
they can have a better chance of
controlling it
there's a big thing that we used to use
with kobe all the time
is i used to ask individuals
if you're interested
in taking
your business
or your basketball game
your football skills your podcast
and this we'd have a room of thousands
and thousands of people
stand up
and everybody would stand up and they
give this big rounding clap and all this
other stuff
if you're interested in taking it to
number one if you're interested yes to
uh the next level for some people it may
not be number one whatever it is
everybody claps up and then i say sit
back down then i would ask him i said
all right
if you're obsessed
with taking your business
your sport
whatever it is to another level stand up
and everybody would stand up again well
i would say well which one is it
which one is it you can't be interested
and you can't be obsessed
interested is a hobby
kobe bryant was not interested
in winning championships he was obsessed
and obsession comes
in the small details that nobody
pays attention
to
and i have a saying
all right
interested people watch obsessed people
change the world
kobe was interested in those small
details that nobody else was interested
in paying attention to
what were those small details for him
everyone talks about
maximizing their time
kobe and i were interested in maximizing
his focus when you maximize your focus
it gave us more it gave us more time
the
having everything laid out for him so he
wouldn't have to worry about
the
what shoes he what shoes he had to wear
where where the t where the tickets had
to go for friends and for the friends
and
family
we would come around and in the
different arenas i would walk the floors
while he was getting dressed and i would
tell him
where
the ball doesn't bounce as well
because on a basketball court it's made
out of wood
all right and they're they're portable
floors and everybody knows
in certain arenas they're dead spots
you force the player into that area if
the ball is going to bounce there it's
not going to it's not going to bounce as
high which gives the team team the
advantage
and a lot of times when they would move
those they would move those pieces
around
so we would walk around bounce the ball
that spot that spot that spot that spot
so we'd get an advantage of the details
that nobody else would pay attention to
that
if we went into that area we know stay
away from that area or if we know we
can't dribble on that that that
particular spot and there was one time
there was a game where
kobe was before the game he was shooting
free throws
and he was like
something isn't something isn't right so
he called the one of the maintenance
guys over he goes are you sure this
basket is right
and the guy said yeah he goes well i
want you to check it for he measured
it was an eighth of an inch off
when you're that obsessed when you pay
that much attention to the to the to the
details
you know it's no different than what you
said about the lighting
and the microphones and the team i've
never seen
i've done quite a few podcasts
we're very selective in who who
we want to sit we want to sit down with
and this is the first time i've seen
this many
individuals were having a conversation
yesterday and i've been thinking about
it the last two days since we had the
conversation the conversation is should
we hire someone full-time to look at the
data and analytics of the episodes when
they go out so we can
if we put an episode out and the title
thumbnail is wrong we can know within 24
hours if we need to change it like we we
know in this conversation which part in
hindsight from looking at the data
people found most interesting because
they pull it back and watch it again
and it's all of these insights which are
there but we want to be the team that is
the team that cares enough about that
about those tiny details because that is
our religion as we say that is what
where we believe we'll find all the
gains that's where the separation is
the separation
is in the details it's in the details
the separation and the clothes you wear
is in the details the sh the shoes the
car that you drive the the house your
your education it doesn't matter whether
you go to the most expensive university
or you drop out of the universe it's the
details you pay attention to
in your studies in whatever your career
choice is
that those are the things that matter
you pay attention to the details in in
your family pay attention to the details
in your kids you pay attention to the
details of what makes your significant
other happy how they react to certain
things
it's people get comfortable
with not having to manage
the details
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as the seasons
have begun to change so has my diet and
um
right now i'm going to be completely
honest with you i'm starting to think a
lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad um and it started to show a
little bit really over the last two
months i go to the gym about 80 of the
time so i track it with 10 of my friends
in a whatsapp group and this tracker
online that we all use together we call
it fitness blockchain and i'm currently
at 81 percent
um so 81 of the days i've done a workout
in the last 150 days right so i'm going
to the gym about six times a week
that's been a little bit impacted by the
derivative live tour but i'm trying to
stick to it
and so one of the things i'm doing now
to reduce my calorie intake and trying
to get back to being nutritionally
complete and all i eat is i'm having the
heel protein shake thank you hill for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one
having worked with a man like kobe and
seeing what he strived for his you know
his focus on legacy his obsession with
his sports and his craft and his
obsession
as many have said
of being better than michael jordan
he's no longer with us tragically
but having seen a man striving for that
greatness in his life and for that
legacy
and having seen how that story ended and
now being able to look back on the
fullness of his life
what was he missing
and the reason i asked this question is
because sometimes
i reflect on my own striving and think
is there something in hindsight
having lived a life where i achieve
those things where i reach the top in
you know my industry in business or in
podcasting wherever it might be or as an
investor that i'm going to realize in
hindsight and go do you know what [ __ ]
legacy might not have mattered as much
as i thought it did it might not have
mattered as much as relationships or
friendships or something else
i always say this the most driven
individuals
they live a life
for many years
and certain times without balance
everybody strives for balance balance
balance
and in order to be that obsessed with
something over and over again
so if you say something that's that was
missing but it was actually a gift
was
his lack of balance
you know there were time now
you can't be
the best
at something
and try to balance everything else
around your life
there is going to be times where things
are going to be
out of balance it's just this
i you know so many individuals talk
about
that
you need more balance you need more
balance you need more else you don't
find balance you create it and it's
different for every individual out there
what
the balance i've created may be
completely different than the balance
you you've cr you've created and there's
certain times in your life that the
scales are definitely going to be
weighing towards one side more than the
other in early part of kobe's kobe's
career it was about
it was about basketball and winning
about basketball and winning
and towards the end of it towards the
end of his career and you know he played
for 20 years it became more less about
winning it was still about basketball
and it became more focused became more
on
spending time with the family but you
have to surround yourself with people
and this is very important to the
listeners
you have to surround yourself with
people
when your life is
unbalanced
with individuals that would be selfish
for you
they understand your obsession they
understand your drive they understand
your attention to detail
no i guarantee it
almost i don't know your whole team
but i guarantee almost everyone on your
team
at some point
every single day is
they become selfish for another
individual so that individual can
perform and do their task at the highest
level
that's how you get closer to balance you
want to get closer to balance don't
continue to add stuff
get closer to balance by deleting the
unessentials
delete the unessentials the most
successful people
and the success when i talk about
success i'm not just talking about
from a financial standpoint whatever
success means to you and whatever
success means to you in your
in your life
they've learned
how to disconnect
they've learned how to delete
the unessentials
because you spend so much time
being obsessed and paying attention to
the details that you don't have time you
don't have focus
for the unessentials the most successful
people
have the smaller circles
when people hear that
there'll be young kids that listen and
they'll
they might stop talking to their family
they might stop calling their girlfriend
and they might say you know what it's
because i just need to be obsessed and
they might compromise things in their
life that lead them to
despair and happiness and those kinds of
things and i always wonder with these
individuals that you've worked with that
are at the highest level that are that
are obsessed
do they prioritize happiness as the goal
as the ultimate goal or is winning the
goal at all costs and in your view
do sometimes they go too far should
happiness be the goal i can't make that
decision for those individuals
my job
if happening happiness could be winning
for them
all right but you don't find happiness
you create it
you're not going to find winning you
have to create you have to create
winning habits
i sat here with a lady who became the
number one youtuber in the world and she
had 15 million subscribers and she was
talking about her obsession she would
get these spreadsheets this was before
the analytics she'd write down how the
video done in each like hour two hours
whatever she was obsessed she becomes
the biggest in the world and in the
process of getting there she realized
that this was she was completely burnt
out miserable depressed and she'd been
like dragged by this obsession to a
place that
made her depressed and eventually in
2019
she quits youtube
and that's what i think sometimes with
our darkness it drags us in a way that
in a less conscious way to a place that
might make us unhappy it does you know
listen winning does not always equate
that winning does not always
equate to happiness it just it just
doesn't for i've had a lot of
individuals that have come to me and
just said this is too intense i'll give
you a great example you know everyone
kobe is known for mama mentality you
know that was that was his thing mama
mentality i've seen mama first of all
mama mentality is not a mentality it's a
lifestyle
that's the first thing i tell
individuals
and once i tell them about the lifestyle
i've seen
mama mentality
destroy more careers than i've seen it
help
too intense
too hot
people want the flame but they don't
want to touch the fire
are you willing to put aside
the things that aren't as important as
aren't as important to you at this
particular moment and i'm not telling
you kids listen don't don't separate
yourself from from your your family but
there's a lot of times that your family
doesn't see the same things that you see
and the same things that you believe in
they've had a certain way of do of doing
things my family very supportive very
supportive but to them
success was
working for
a institution
that you got a paycheck every single two
weeks
you got health
insurance you got paid vacation
you got a 401k
that was their definition
of success
and happiness
to me
none of that would have made me happy
so when you talk about creating
happiness are you creating happiness
that you you've created or somebody else
has created for you are you writing your
story of happiness or did somebody else
write your story of happiness and hand
it to you and say here this is how you
become happy
one of the things i think i've struggled
with in my life is knowing if something
is something i want or if it's
scratching
an insecurity i have so
insecurity as you know is one of the
greatest motivators in the world
then it can turn into an obsession so if
you're bullied in school you might want
to become famous
because that in your view is acceptance
right so you see face you strive and
then the minute you get a taste of fame
maybe because you start a youtube
channel you triple down because people
are clapping for you and this is
everything that didn't happen when you
were a kid this is it's filling that
void but is that happiness or am i just
using external validation to cover a
wound in me and i see this in great
people all the time i always try and get
to the bottom of the pain as we talked
about the darkness the pain the trauma
or whatever that's actually driving them
and i i guess my conclusion has been
that you just need to be conscious
of of that
when you talked about you know that
insecurity that that darkness that need
for for to be valid to be validated
what's going is it controlling you or
are you controlling it
you know the one thing that listen there
was a point where
as obsessed as michael was with
basketball
all right he never let the sport control
him
let he never let that sport control him
he he was like
the there are certain things within this
game yes i have to follow these rules i
have to do things but there are certain
things that i still have to be in charge
of my life i still have to be in charge
of who i am i still have to be in charge
of of my brand
and then when what happens is when you
let external things
and you start playing for the for the
wrong reason a lot of individuals play
always and this is the thing in with in
sports now everyone talks about building
their brand
building their brand
all right and if you follow the people
who have had the greatest success
building their brand is they just
outperform individuals they put a better
product out there do your job better
than anybody else and your brand will
build it itself
so when people look for that happiness
factor
is your foundation and your fundamental
principles so strong
that
if this thing was to go away
could you still create happiness and
success all over again if your
foundation and principles are extremely
strong no matter what endeavor it is you
look at the most successful people in
business
and everything else
they've gone to do multiple things
that have allowed them to create
different levels of happiness within
that confined circle
you know
michael had
basketball
then he had
the shoe brand now he's got other now
he's got other other endeavors he's
involved in you know a lot of
philanthropy things the competitive
nature doesn't stop and everybody thinks
you can only be happy with one one
certain aspect in your in your life in
your life you can create happiness in
multiple things in your life and if it
gets to the point where it is burning it
is burning you out that means it's time
for you for that you are no longer
obsessed with that thing anymore and
it's time for you to beco
become obsessed with something else and
it could be
this stage in your life where your
success and your happiness is now
listen i just want to create happiness
for myself and for the individuals
around me and on that point of balance
was michael ever direct with you about
the sacrifice you would have to make to
come on that journey with him
the first thing he told me was you
better keep up
and what did he mean by that
what he meant by that is not
as a trainer
keep up in life
because this ride we don't know which
direction it's going to go on we don't
know if it's going up down sideways but
be ready for anything this throws at us
interestingly
that's what you knew
he meant
one of the reasons i get along so well
with all my clients professionally
business-wise socially or everybody
because they know i'm just as messed up
as they are
and i don't judge them
my
my daughter always says she goes
dad
you have no weird r
she goes nothing to you is weird
nothing to you and i was when i see
something i just say interesting
i want to know
how that what that person is doing and
why they're doing it
and what's fueling that desire
and also
what are they using that desire what are
they going to fuel it with
with other individuals
one of the stories i tell
years when i first started when i
started first started working with
with uh mj
and this is
a lot of your listeners will be too
young to remember this
but
the recording devices back then was
called a betamax
videotape he's stuck in so what i would
do is i'd have to be at the basketball
games very early
make sure everything was prepped and he
he was he was ready to go and we were
always the last individuals to leave
i'd rewatch
the game
i would count his steps
there was no fitbit back then there was
no no tracking measurements or so forth
well
i needed in my thought and this went
back to my process of
not what to think how to think
is
well how can i prepare him for his next
workout
in the morning
if i don't know
how much physical activity
and the differences between the right
and left side so i would literally count
this is how many steps he took left this
is how many steps he took right this is
how many times he took backwards this is
how many times he left landed on his
right foot this is how many times he
landed on his left foot so i'd have all
this data
so the next morning when i would get up
i'd be able to plan okay you know what
mj
this side you use your
you use your left leg 60 more than you
use your right leg but you use your
right hand more than you use you're like
okay so this is what we're going to do
from a workout standpoint now this is
what we're going to do from a training
standpoint because one side is going to
need different training than the other
side is going to need so we would have
different exercises where he'd have 50
pounds in one hand and 10 in the other
or the certain amount of reps on this
exercise and certain amount of reps on
this exercise certain time spent over
here a certain time spent over here
there was no books out there that told
me this is this was the right thing to
do
i just knew it was right
i just i just knew it was right
and now they use this methodology all
the time so interesting i was thinking
about that because really interesting
when you said that there was no books
out there and tends to be the case with
pioneers and innovators and people that
think from first principles that they
they do it before the books are
published yeah and once the books are
published it's probably too late yeah
people are using math i i stuff we were
doing with him 30 years ago people are
just now using them like
was that music to his ears when he knew
that his
sports enhancement specialist was going
to such a degree of detail could you did
you know that that that was proving to
him that you cared and you were as
obsessed as he was yes
you know he gave me one of the best
compliments that you can ever get
at the highest level when somebody else
would say hey
i want to hi i want to hire tim he goes
i don't pay tim to train me he goes i
pay him not to train anybody else
that is a big compliment
he ultimately introduced you to somebody
else when he retired and stepped out of
the game after 15 years of you working
together which was kobe and i found it
really intriguing that when he
introduced you to kobe
he lovingly used the word [ __ ]
when he introduced you to kobe so he
said like i'm not using tim anymore so
no kobe you can uh you can work with him
why did he use the word [ __ ]
you know what
as in to become as individuals become
more successful
everybody around them becomes yes people
nobody wanted to say no to michael
jordan
oh i was that individual
we had many times
we had very heated short arguments
there were like
three words which i won't say because
it'll it'll offend a lot of your
listeners
but that was the end of the con that was
the end of the conversation i said mj
you hired me
to do
a job at the highest level
i said you cannot do a job at the
highest level without accountability
i said once the accountability
is broken between us
then it's time for you to find another
individual
so he held me accountable i held him
accountable and when somebody says you
better keep up
as a person's star starts to grow the
accountability has a tendency to get
less
because now you don't pay attention to
the details as much as much because
you've you feel like i've achieved it
i've gotten there it's a it's a lot
easier
staying on the top is not the same thing
as reaching the top
many individuals can reach the top but
very few individuals
stay at the top because the
accountability among their team and
among themselves
starts to deteriorate once they've
reached the top
and what does that deterioration in
accountability look like what are the
signs of it
i give you great example
when
people perform at the highest level in
business
sometimes a boss
or the person above them ceo whatever's
allowed you know what man their numbers
are so good
we're going to let them
we're not going to hold them accountable
for this this and this you know they're
still performing they might may not be
performing at the highest level but
they're still performing at a top level
so now you have that little crack
and that little crack gets a little
bigger
and a little bigger
and a little bigger michael in the last
dance said something he goes i never
asked any of my teammates to do anything
that i didn't do
you talk about
the greatest ever play the game
he didn't have to have anybody else hold
him accountable he was
i'm not going to ask you to do anything
that i'm not going to do myself
so as individuals once they've reached
that
pinnacle and they get their arms out and
they start looking down
and say i finally reached the top of
this mountaintop
those are all the right things to do
don't exhale
because the air is so much thinner
up on the top
than it is on the climb to the top
and if you exhale
the next breath you have to catch
will not have the same effect you'll
have to catch multiple breaths over and
over and over again that's why you see
some of these at some of these
individuals
that
retire from a sport they come back or
you see a ceo of a company leave a
company take a year off and now they
become a ceo of an uh of a of another
company
they can't exhale
in chapter five of your book you you
speak to some of these things that
michael would do to to his teammates um
one of them is he would mock his
teammates into dedication right you see
this in the last dance where he's
cracking jokes at them but you know that
the jokes there's these aren't jokes
there's intention behind the jokes yes
he's trying to get them to run faster or
to train harder or whatever can you give
me a window into what you saw in terms
of the way that michael would treat his
teammates in order to get the best out
of him that some might consider to be
in the modern day and age where we're
very soft especially in the business
world
toxic
it worked for him and it was the only
the only way he knew he knew how and
it's a lot of people may consider things
toxic when they initially start out but
then when you see the end result or when
your career is over with or when you're
with a different organization you look
at it and say you know what i really
miss that
i give an example
of
flowers
when
you gift roses or your gifted roses or
any types of flowers
they cut the thorns off
because the thorns you know are prickly
and so forth well when you cut the
thorns off
a rose you decrease its lifespan
so a lot of individuals that have been
thorns in your life
have actually allowed you to propel
to places that you would never be able
to propel before
and you don't miss it until this thorn
is not when that thorn is no longer
there
so when michael
was constantly pushing his players
getting them to l
everybody knew he was not coming down to
their level he didn't expect everybody
to come up to his level but he knew
there was another level for each and for
each individual
and he just wanted you to perform at the
highest level and he wanted you to have
a taste of winning not just once but
numerous times over and over again and
he had to be genuine to who he who he
was
the one of the things that i talk about
in my other book relentless one of the
13 i said you know exactly who you are
he knew exactly who
he was he knew who he can communicate
with
and say certain things
and he knew when not to say certain
things and have another individual talk
to that person but when he spoke
everybody everybody listens they're if
you watch practices
everybody would come into the practice
and they'd be laughing and kind of
joking and having a having a good time
and so forth and as soon as
that whistle was blown
silence
and michael always said i practice so
hard and we all need to practice so hard
so the games become easier
do you think he used those thorns as
well as a bit of a filter
in terms of filtering out the teammates
that he didn't think were yes were good
enough yes
i won't say they were good enough as one
he that he could trust in certain
situations trust me it was the the
thorns were more for trust how how can
can i keep poking you oh how many times
can i keep poking you
and see are you going to come back are
you going to come back what what what's
your adversity tolerance
because there's going to be certain
situations
that can i trus can i trust you
can i trust you in that situation and if
you look throughout his career there's
very few people when the game was on the
line that he would trust to pass the
ball to and say hey this is what's going
to happen very very few and all those
individuals
that he did that with
at some point
in their career stood up to him and
challenged him
isn't that interesting
it's almost a bit of a paradox the the
fact that
we trust those most and that's the
sounds
from everything i've read like much of
the reason why he trusted you
was because he knew you had put truth at
the the front of everything you do and
to be honest i think i've probably said
this to my team before but the people
that are a most valuable
um in my circle are those that are do
you have a voice and are willing to give
it to me despite my
um
despite my success yeah those are the
ones you want you want to keep around
right you look yeah i definitely keep
those individuals definitely keep those
individuals around i
just
it's too easy
too many times
we let people off the hook
i can't let an individual off the hook
because it's too easy think about the
time that you left you let somebody off
the hook
how'd it turn out for you
badly the first example that came to
mind was
someone who i hired to lead one of our
countries for our for our company
and their behavior was not up to
standard and i procrastinated on it for
too long for
for more than a year
and it cost me every day when i say cost
i mean it was a seven figure cost to our
company and eventually i had to make the
decision that i should have made it at
the start right i should have but for
some reason i was for reasons i now
clearly understand i was avoiding the
decision and letting the person off the
hook how many years ago was that
um i think now it'd be four years ago
all right if that same situation
happened now how quickly would you
remember oh so fast all right so so
quickly and i have subsequently and i
when i do respond in that way i recite
that story right to the people around me
i go four years ago this happened and
it's my single biggest regret in
business because i procrastinated on
making a decision i knew i had to make i
let the person off the hook so this is
why today four years later we're making
this decision as soon as we possibly can
winning doesn't make you heartless
but it teaches you to use your heart
less
four years ago
you were using your heart
yeah now
you'd use your heart you still have a
heart but you'd use it less
and my brain more
exactly yeah
mind over feelings
and when we're faced with those tough
decisions for me what i learned in
hindsight is
it felt like difficulty in the moment
that's why part of the reason i
procrastinated on the decision but in
hindsight it caused so much more
difficulty
in the long term so it's really that
like ballot the the wisdom i got from it
is you know a tough decision
today or you can make the same decision
but in a year's time when it becomes
when the cost and the implications of
the decision are even greater and it's
had a time to drag you or pull you down
or to make you lose games whatever it
might be or lose money in business and
so that decisiveness and putting mind
over matter is something that i've
definitely developed as
a ceo
one of the things you said which i found
really um
thought-provoking and it kind of bucked
the trend in chapter 12 of your book is
when someone says showing up is half the
battle you're looking at an individual
who is already losing the battle people
say that all the time showing up is half
the battle showing up is none of the
battle
you showed up
i showed up
were we supposed to not do the podcast
and go have a drink
showing up is none of the battle people
want accolades and rewards for doing
things that they're supposed to do
people want to get acknowledged for
things that you're supposed you're
supposed to show up you guys supposed to
practice you're supposed to perform
you're supposed to get results
no people people have a hard time
understanding now the difference between
feedback and criticism it's exactly the
same thing it's just how you hear it
you in order to get anything anything in
life and to get anywhere you must show
up if you think showing up is winning
you've already you've already lost the
battle you've already lost a battle
people want to get a medal for doing the
for doing the easy things people show up
every single day
people show up every single day and are
dealing with circumstances that are
beyond your imagination
they still show up
i i love to give examples to
individuals that just happened
we're sitting in a completely different
location of where this podcast was
originally supposed to be done in
showing up and you were congratulating
yourself first hey showing up is half
the battle
you'd have been like oh well we showed
up here we won
he's like all right no
we actually showed up and we got thrown
out now we got to go show up somewhere
else
and make this thing all work again
and people come back and say oh you know
what you showed up don't worry about it
you won that battle today
no do you know that story so we landed
in la and we got to the hotel and the
hotel
um offered us how to fill us a certain
room in the penthouse suite where we
felt we could replicate
the aesthetic we need to make the show
successful we're looking for somewhere
where it feels like you are in my
because we've recorded the uk in my
house sure so it needs to feel at home
because of the nature of the
conversation we're having it needs to be
details yeah right so we got to the
hotel they're like well you can have you
know the penthouse week there's one day
it's booked for so for three of the
episodes
the set will change and i was like we
don't want that to change so they said
well there's a meeting room we'll give
it to you completely free at the back
we can't do it in a meeting room they
showed us six or seven rooms they took
us around every room in the hotel
no
so although the podcast was two days
away and we had 20 odd guests coming
sure we as a team because again our
religion is to care about the details
looked for somewhere else we went on
viewing so we found this place
insanely inexpensive place as you've
seen but uh but we we've always believed
in those details we always believe it
really matters and then jack and the
team and berta to their credit have
built this whole entire set which nobody
can see
in in the next in the next 24 hours
running back and forth from target we
don't have to do that but we because
we've as you said earlier we've seen the
outcome of that suffering now
and once you've tasted it you can't
unsee it right
you can't unsee it you just can't
you can't i you know people always said
you know
you know you can't
you can't
forget what you've seen you can't
unlearn what you've learned
you just you get you can't you can you
can you can't unlearn it you can learn
from it and learn other things on top of
it but you're never going to unlearn
those things you're never going to be
able to unsee the things that that you
that you've seen and that's when people
just don't under they just don't
understand that they they can't they
can't see and understand your level of
craziness they can't see your level of
of obsession
and then once you those things no longer
matter for you
then you know it's time to move on to
another endeavor which you've already
have
in your previous thing you know when you
when you talked earlier about
relationships we talked about the
relationships of those around you and
how that can be impacted you we talked
about at the very start of this
conversation about our dark sides
one of the ways we sometimes see the
consequences of our dark sides is in
our romantic relationships one of the
ways we see the consequences of our
obsession
is in our romantic relationships so tell
me from a both a personal perspective as
tim
the impact that your dark side and
obsession and your desire to win and be
great has had on your
relationships and those
that you've coached and you've worked
with
from a personal standpoint
i will say this winning will cost you
everything but we'll reward you with so
much more
it's going to cost you everything
and i every decision i've made
i knew what the consequences
was i knew what the cost was going to be
it may have not been at that particular
moment but i knew down the line if i go
do this decision if i go work with this
individual or i decide to do this now
somewhere down the line this is what
it's this is what it's going to cost
this is what it's going to cost me i
tell the story in the in the book
where
my daughter came up to me when i was
when she was like
five years old
and says daddy why do you travel so much
and so i said sweetheart this is how i
take care of the family this is how i
provide for you it's how i take care of
mom this is how i put a roof over the
head this is how i put food on the table
she goes daddy if i eat less
will you stay or more
at age five
i was packing for a trip
now
if this was
a fairy tale
i'd unpack my bag
i'd have grabbed her hand we'd have went
out for ice cream
i kept packing
now
i'm not telling anybody out there that's
a decision they should make
but that was my decision
and then many years later i sat down my
daughter
and i said hey
i want to talk to you
and i wanted to discuss with her why dad
is the way he is
and before i could even start she goes
dad i understand
she goes i understand
she was i could see what you provided
for mom and i
i could see the sacrifices you made
for us
was it important for you to hear that
yes very important
and i just never knew when the right
time was
and then one day i just said this is the
day
this is the day she goes you taught me
how to make the toughest decisions in
life
because not only taught me you showed me
you told me how to be independent
when to be dependent when to be
independent
so sometimes when you think you're
making
the wrong decision or you have to making
the toughest decision
because you're thinking about somebody
else and the consequences
if you think
the price of winning is too high
wait till you get the bill from regret
and that bill from regret is
generational
and there's a lot of people listening to
this that that bill has been passed on
from generation to generation and you
are holding that bill right now and
somebody
in some one of your generations has to
pay that bill off
in order for the generation
to move on
and the only way that bill gets paid off
is you got to be willing
to make
the hardest decisions
the other side of that story is
i would often fly
my family was in chicago
i was doing work
on the west coast
so when she had a school play
when she had a volleyball game
i would fly
from the west coast land in chicago
watch her performance for 45 minutes to
an hour
and get on the plane that same night and
be back for my client the next day
and there was a lot of times where i
didn't even get a chance to speak to her
she just knew i was in the audience
because i had it was the only flight to
get back
those are the parts nobody remembers
everybody remembers
one event you don't show up for
and i guaranteed every individual who's
one at multiple things who's been
successful at many things over and over
again
at some point
in your career some point in your life
you forgot a very important date you
missed an event you just you just did
but nobody wants to talk about it
because people are going to judge you on
that one
thing
tim
thank you my pleasure honestly uh you've
sent me on a you know my job is to sit
you're asking questions but my brain has
been running for many many reasons i
feel like i need to go and sit down
upstairs and just reflect on a lot of
things you've said it's um
speaking to you today was it will remain
one of the biggest honors i've had on
this podcast because you're a very very
um special proposition thank you we have
a closing tradition on this this podcast
where we asked guests
uh to leave a question for the next
guest and i don't get to see the
question until i open the book so
what is one mistake
you've made
you've been scared to address or
reconcile
every mistake i've made i've reconciled
i've owned up to it
whether they accept it or not
people have asked me to apologize for
things i shouldn't have apologized for
if people had to make a mistake i would
say that would be one of the a lot a few
times i apologize for things i should
have not apologized for
thank you you're welcome
we are all looking for ways to live a
little bit more sustainably and to make
more conscious choices in our day-to-day
routines so when a brand like my energy
who i've spoken about before offered to
sponsor this podcast i felt like and i
knew deep down inside that i had to help
them share their mission to create an
even greener world it feels like there's
not much more fulfilling than that and
their products provide an easy and cost
effective way to make a sustainable
switch in your life and they've got some
existing new products coming out that i
can't wait to use myself and i'll let
you know as i use those products how i
get on so if you're a my energy customer
at the moment let me know your favorite
products down below in the comments
section and if you haven't checked them
out yet go to myenergy.com and find out
a lot more about who they are and what
they're doing if you're one of those
people that wants to make a sustainable
switch
myenergy.com is the place for you
[Music]
bye